I have a present that they gave us oh
then I have the keys to the mailbox keys
to the actual house and then on top of
that we got the garage door opener it's
nice what are you trying to say then
what does that mean it means we're
moving in Windows bf guys
oMG today's the day we get to pack all
this up in previous videos we have been
saying that we've been purging and we
have little by little but to be
completely honest with you we did not
get rid of the big pieces like the
furniture that we wanted to get rid of
before we moved so unfortunately we're
gonna be bringing all that stuff with us
to the new house and then figuring out
how to get rid of it once we're over
there because time ran out we have been
very busy we haven't been able to focus
on like putting this stuff up online to
sell like we have equipment to and a lot
of you guys have asked if KC is posting
up his cameras on eBay or anything like
that we do eventually want to post
things up online to sell so we will keep
you guys posted when that will happen
and then we'll give you guys links if
you want to purchase any of our stuff
but most of the things that like the
little stuff we did give to my aunt she
came two nights ago and she picked up
like a whole nother round of stuff if
you look at our place
it looks like nothing has been done but
if you look really really really closely
I actually did get rid of a lot of stuff
these shelves used to be a lot more
packed with things like little trinkets
and stuff and I got rid of a lot of them
it looks complete but I got rid of a lot
of stuff and the same with like some
books that we didn't really want we got
rid of and just throughout the entire
house we have been getting rid of things
here and there but today's the date
today the big day that we get to box
everything up so today's Friday
the plan is box everything up and as we
box continue to purge if there are
things to purge then tomorrow morning we
have movers scheduled to come in pick up
the boxes and move them to the new place
and same
furniture and stuff technically
tomorrow's the big big big big day cuz
that's the date we're really taking
things out of here but today is a big
day for us because we get to box
everything up here you get to do the
work today tomorrow someone else doesn't
work someone else moves it yeah so Isaac
went to school this morning and he's
like mom when I come back from school
everything's gonna be boxed up and I'm
like well that's the plan son hopefully
hopefully that that's what happens today
that is the plan right but another thing
is for us to go to our new house and
pick up the keys and then that's when
like it's officially ours so luckily yes
all the wires that we were talking about
before it like the wire transfers for
the down payment
they all went through we got it all I
don't think they have the certificate
from the city as of this moment yet but
they're trying to get it by the end of
the day so then tomorrow we can start
moving in yeah whole bunch of grown-up
stuff okay I really gotta stop
procrastinating and I gotta start
packing this stuff up we're gonna set up
a time lapse and then you guys will see
this whole room transform right before
your eyes you know I write now that me
saying this made me think of Isaac when
he was like oh man you guys are lucky
with the whole boxes I got skipped ahead
yeah you're gonna get to skip ahead but
us in real life we got to do all the
work and like actually go through it
it's real time anyway I know in real
life like click
[Music]
all right we got four boxes packed
doesn't seem like very much but it was
Japan but that's enough to clear out the
room yeah look at this we didn't get a
chance to like treasure the last of last
moments of our living room I know
whatever I'm really proud of you for
being able to that created the living
room was beautiful he's pretty the
lights are so up you know probably not
next this is probably gonna be the last
thing big shout out to our friends Anna
and Jeremy they gave us their boxes cuz
they've just recently moved the same
boxes were used by Dan and Jun and I
think they all got the boxes originally
from Barton geo because I could tell
Gio's handwriting so this is kind of
cool we've all been using the same boxes
who've been moving into our brand-new
home so it's kind of cute and then they
also like really organized all of this
like pecking pecking materials and stuff
so it's really cool we also have boxes
saved from the last time we moved we
just borrowed just borrowed too when she
moved out so that's kind of cute well
it's kind of like the you know the
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants or
whatever but we have that with with
boxes moving boxes anyway we're gonna
take a break and then we're gonna eat
and then tackle upstairs next because
everything else that's left here I'm
like I don't know the movers could
figure it out like the blankets and the
pillows we'll put in bags and then that
stuff I don't know what to do with that
cuz they don't fit in a box so we're
probably gonna just put them in my car
or something and just hand-deliver them
ourselves there's just a whole bunch of
stuff we got to figure out I started
getting very overwhelmed cuz I'm like oh
my gosh there's so many things about
this we're gonna do this we have a
checklist of rooms right a bedroom
kitchen better going to a master yeah
and then bathrooms whatever that's like
what two seven items on the list one's
down yeah
and I'll figure it out we should have
just cancelled JK news yesterday or
cancelled are you sad look visually
dusty it's super dusty but yeah I
started getting very overwhelmed around
like oh my goodness we need to do this
all today and tomorrow this is not
enough time we'll make it work we'll
make it look there's so much to do so
little time you got the house officials
it's fully funded now okay boys I mean
we can we're gonna get a call from the
other guys to pick up our keys but as of
this moment shoes like congratulations
that house is yours
it's officially ours we just gotta go
get our keys so today's the day that we
get ours yes yes yes yes
now you know I've always - - every time
existed I was like does it feel like
your house does it feel like your house
as you can feel like your house now it
feels like my house because now I know
it's my house all the entire time has
just been like oh we're gonna get this
house but it's never been our house but
now it's ours we have lunch all fed up
some leftover tamales and some coleslaw
and then I got the call at the comb so
he actually says we should be expecting
another call because this was the the
mortgage people the the people that have
funded the house like the loan people
they're the ones that are the
gatekeepers into whether or not we can
have our house because we are not rich
we don't have this amount of money in
cash you need it alone and so now that
the loan is funded that means it's our
house next step getting keys yes and
just packing up this house this house
kitchens next ok at exactly 12:00 p.m.
on February 28th 2020 we got our house
funded we are homeowners dance crazy
homeowners homeowners I was actually you
know like you know you're going to the
movement process like earlier this
morning whatever yeah but this is
exactly the kind of news I think we
motivate us to get as excited because
part are like enthusiasm
we're really moving to our house our
hell it can't wait
our house oh my goodness I can't believe
it our names are on the deed like the
title of the house
our names are if getting married wasn't
like the the right of passage to become
adults feel like this today became adult
now this a little bit never at all now
we have a mortgage to pay Oh No yeah
then we got property taxes to worry
about in the next 30 years
yeah it's so crazy I'm excited
[Music]
alright appear on the road yes we're
really go to the house the new house our
house we own this house we picked up
Isaac from school Isaac are you excited
yeah yeah so as soon as we get home
you're gonna be packing up your own
bedroom dude
yeah our own room I think you're old
enough now you can handle it all on your
own
yeah we got the phone call earlier that
means we officially owned our home
[Music]
are you excited are you sad I'm more
excited than sad yeah why is that
because I'm gonna miss my friends are
you still gonna see them for the rest of
the school year true yeah we decided
that we're going to do the commute out
to this side of the city to continue to
take Isaac to school for the rest of the
school year and then once he enters
seventh grade that's gonna be the new
school all right so a little update on
the packing we have six boxes packed so
far four for the living room two for the
kitchen but the kitchen is gonna be a
beast I'm assuming that we're gonna need
about ten boxes for the kitchen all
together and everything so big and like
it takes up a lot of things we're trying
to maximize all the boxes that we have
I'm actually kind of concerned maybe you
don't have enough box or anything oh we
totally have enough okay nevermind
because of all the boxes that we have on
the other side of the garage but yeah
we've been at it for about four hours
since the morning
and it doesn't look like we've started
at all it looks exactly the same exactly
but yeah it's because of the major
pieces of furniture that's kind of what
makes it feel like we haven't done
anything
but if you open cupboards I have a
present that they gave us
oh then I have the keys to the mailbox
keys to the actual house whoo
and then on top of that we got the
garage door opener it's nice what are
you trying to say then what does that
mean means we're moving in we're moving
in soon the house is ours
yeah nice I want to be in the new house
with the new community new people to
meet yeah yeah new people to get used to
oh yeah has this is feel any different
from all the other times they moved no
it doesn't feel any different
oh no I just he's actually our house and
this house is bigger too and it's
actually one piece ting oh yeah
no shared walls so true that's pretty
cool do you like the neighborhood yeah
yes it's very nice they explore and
stuff and do your own thing have your
own adventures yeah all right it's very
um very big
[Music]
you're about to enter the house as
homeowners now for the first time
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You Kevin woke up but they just
thank you thank you so much all the
emotions are hitting you all at once oh
yeah and they got the grill back we're
girls from eggs yeah week it became a
couple of days ago right and then like
it was missing like somebody came in
here and took it yeah
[Music]
you're so nice if you want to change it
for the other one
thank you guys thank you enjoy that bar
oh yeah that's awesome so true so true
alright so Kevin our real-estate agent
just left and now we are left to
ourselves and our brand-new house we
haven't yet go-go-go-go
shoes
[Applause]
okay now we have to work on filling up
the entire all the windows we have to do
like the trash bags situation oh we have
to fix back master bedroom I fix toilets
[Music]
bedroom oh I see where's Isaac it's not
are you true until Isaac's in here yeah
Isaac's bedroom this is funny
walking downstairs do you remember when
we were walking through that wall
yeah where it goes oh yeah there's this
there's some vlogs where we walked
through the the framing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so now we're driving around back to take
our car to park it inside the garage for
the very very first time and to pop that
cherry - yep oh my goodness first time
first time I like cars going into our
garage and it just happened and it's
happening right now and it happened
that's a beautiful car inside of
beautiful garage peace out house
[Music]